on parle d'un sujet un petit peu plus
grave ce sont les stars est ce qu'on
appelle le burn out en anglais c'est un
peu la dépression quand on pète un plomb
et aujourd'hui voilà invité du canal
football club
quelques jours le footballeur adil rami
a expliqué avoir été victime justement
de ce fameux barn out après le mondial
où la juge estime que j'ai pas eu assez
de vacances j'ai pas eu le temps de le
vider la tête et donc j'ai fait une
dépression donc regarder notamment la
vidéo il en a parlé moi j'ai le band a
exactement eu à discuter et essayer de
trouver des solutions je savais je
savais que j'étais pas à 100%
mentalement et physiquement mais j'en ai
parlé j'ai même eu au téléphone
un coach mental et j'essaie de te
comprendre et tout ça mais oui c'était
assez abordable c'est à dire que même
l'odeur de la pelouse la santé même plus
de vouloir taper des attaquants que
j'avais même pu l'emmener taper je me
forçais mais j'y arrivais pas gt gt et
gris avec mon entourage avec les gens
qui vivent autour de moi et chose que je
te vois là lorsqu'il faut savoir s'il y
en a beaucoup que d'en parler maintenant
il y avait mieux à leur bain on le sait
ya brad pitt qui a dit je me cachais de
la célébrité je fumais j'étais assis
c'est moi chez moi sur mon canapé je me
détestais yahia patricia kaas quant à
parler il ya des gens beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup moins célèbre conte iii de
l'entente que dans tpm ep ya pas très
longtemps le le connard qui est devant
vous voilà il des moments où la vie ça
va un petit peu moins bien mais voilà
est-ce que esker est ce qu on les plaint
oui ou non c'est la question qu'on vous
a posé et il ya beaucoup c'est très très
partagés luc par exemple pour vous non
il faut pas les plaindre c'est à dire
que quand on est célèbre et fonctions
que tout aille bien on n'a pas la rage
devrait plaindre ali rahni parce que ces
vacances ont pas été assez longue il est
parti un mois et demi quad mais c'est
ridicule ça qui est pas que ça va jouer
un match à la coupe du monde n'a pas
arrêté sa musique sur la pelouse soit il
à la barre la route passe mal à la
pression de regarder les matchs mais il
ya d'autres gens qu'il faut plaindre que
adil rami ou les pme ça c'est à 400
d'entendre ça lui c'est quand quelqu'un
vous dit en ce moment ça va pas bien on
vous dit bah ya des gens qui sont
handicapés bien sûr qui a toujours plus
mal que vous n'avez pas bien vous n'êtes
pas bien je n'ai pas besoin de dire à
tout le monde qu'on va pas bien on
possède la meilleure bière de sourires
et battant patatras tout le monde pas
tout le monde mathieu en face à cannes
en mai lui qui excusez moi
le burn out c'est une maladie oui je
veux pas dire je ne vais pas plaindre
quelqu'un de malade sous prétexte qu'il
est connu dans leur note fait de mal a
dit serena
c'est une dépression est une maladie la
dépression n'a pas chômé mathieu le burn
out est une maladie voilà on était sûr
les stars et le burn-out jarre te ment
et donc on en parlait et on disait que
voilà les stars aujourd'hui le disent de
plus en plus aux le dire parce que c'est
une manne devrait maladie aux dires
parfois j'ai fait une dépression
justin bieber a dit qu'il a fait une
grosse dépression il fumait beaucoup il
a pris de la drogue
on peut comprendre aussi que ces gens
pas voilà il peut gagner 300 millions
d'euros par an quand dans ta tête ça
fonctionne plus ça fonctionne plus je
disais est ce qu'il faut les plaindre ou
non et sébastien vous dites non faut pas
les plaindre pourquoi quand c'est quand
c'est vrai on peut les plaindre mais
l'expérience que j'ai en suivant les
stars notamment aux états unis où à
chaque fois qu'on nous parlait d'un
beurre
out nous on allait vérifier c'était une
cure de désintoxication donc souvent la
fête c'est vrai aux excès en tous genres
sur une période prolongée
alors ils sont fatigués ils se
retrouvent en cure ils appellent ça un
burn out et le burn-out desservira
craquage mais je suis pas d'accord qu'on
se croit déjà par rapport aux joueurs de
l'équipe de france parce que j'ai un peu
vécu au travers de avec la main ah oui
donc bah il expliqué et je sais que
voilà et c'est quand même une pression
est longue énorme qu'ils ont sur les
épaules ils sont un peu coupés du monde
pendant toute cette compétition ils
reviennent en france ils sont adulés et
puis bah ils ont eu cette impression en
fait que batou ressort d'un coup et il y
en a énormément qui se sont blessés il
ya beaucoup de joueurs qui c'est vous
qui l'avez connu par exemple benjamin il
revient à benjamin pas vert vient de la
coupe du monde il la gagne il va jouer
il connaît un début de saison un petit
peu plus compliqué blessé est blessé
c'est difficile de la passion du mal en
fait oui ça a été on oublie finalement
pour les assurances on peut pas dire
hier soir sébastien plus tard elles sont
assurées et si on dit au à la prochaine
production et ses grilles et il a pris
de la drogue
et ça veut dire il a faim la prochaine
fois catherine on n'a pas relevé à temps
que cela donne en régie avec guillaume
vous dirai très bien ensemble
l'année où tu serais trop dit que c'est
l'énergie ça donne gagnant non j'étais
pas regarder mais tu ne vois plutôt une
cataracte ma chérie
magali et des infos sur radio 1 me
trouve très injuste avec adil rami c'est
qu'en fait il s'est fait lyncher sur les
réseaux sociaux parce qu'effectivement
il n'a pas joué donc tout le monde lui a
dit mais pourquoi tu rentres tu as pts
et pas sur le terrain et c'est donc il
se fait massacrer sur les réseaux il a
le courage pour un homme de l'assumer de
le dire et puis c'est quand même
massacrés alors qu il dit juste qu'ils
pensaient ce qu'il ressent et ce à un
être humain avant tout donc je vous
trouve assez dur et la nuit en toile
alors qu'elle était très honnête et très
franc sur ce qui les a été très
important dans cette équipe même s'il
n'a pas joué là c'est lui qui sait lui
on n'a pas parlé de lui en faire
ticulier open dernière un dernier mot
parce que je suis assez je suis assez
étonné par daniel moreau mais oui parce
qu'il est plein de noms worn out il ya
la dépression ou ça peut être quelque
chose de personnel et ça le burn out
c'est vraiment il ya un mot d'allemand
et le travail c'est là la pression au
travail c'est déjà cédé chose que des
millions de gens ne vivent
moi je prends l'exemple de lucie lucas
qui était qui et qui a interpellé rete
et clem là sur tf1 charmante jeune fille
elle a fait un burn out et elle dit j'ai
pu m'arrêter six mois pour profiter de
mes enfants faire une pause parce
qu'elle est énormément pays sur un
téléfilm qui fait ça dans les annales et
voilà ça on dirait répondants tmg pour
rome s'est pas relancé mais c'est pas
vrai et il ya les salariés qui peut se
faire arrêter
évidemment à l'ordre des mots arrêté
avec la vraie vie la vraie vie ccc ccc
convient pas c'est pas l'argent qui
change la vie
donc moi dans le bureau des plaintes si
vous voulez c'est à vous ma gare c'est
aujourd'hui un son c'est pas possible
cette émission ton d'âge les français ça
ça m'intéresse c'est la vie qui
m'intéresse ce ter qui ont vécu un burn
out on les plaint à 62%
les gens comprennent